hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter 10 of thomas hobbes leviathan
has a
rather curious title of power worth
dignity
honor and worthiness and if you look at
the
the chapter itself you notice that he
gives a lot
of scope to discussing what honor
actually consists in and you can ask
yourself why
is this all put together here and the
answer to that is you know remember that
thomas hobbes is trying to provide
a new philosophy which is supposed to
clarify
everything that needs to be clarified
particularly about social
and political life and the terminology
or language or concept
that we use for making sense out of
things so this is part of his
larger framework and system
and he's going to define each of these
important terms in ways that
are reflective of other authors
but also are really distinct to his
own approach and we have five main terms
here right we have
power which is the first thing that he
discusses and we'll we'll go into that a
bit
value or worth this is directly tied to
power but it introduces another concept
honor which is connected with
value or worth but also brings in yet
another concept
dignity which is similar to honor but
in a somewhat different twist and then
finally at the very end of the chapter
he brings in worthiness almost as an
after thought
and says well it's not this it's not
this it's actually
this so let's look at each of these
in turn and then we'll look at some of
them in a little bit more detail
and talk about how they how they come
together so
power is what he begins with and it
tells us that the power
of a person to take it universally is a
person's
present means to obtain some future
apparent
good now that's rather abstract but if
you think it through
it's not that hard to to fathom right
what does it mean
so the the means the the ability
the uh things that that this person can
put on the table
that will allow them to attain something
that appears to be a good
it could be a real good or it can just
be something that's apparent as a good
for them
and as we're going to notice power is
something that can be
transferred or or shared or harnessed
so my ability to do to attain
some present good for example and
explaining thomas hobbs to you if that's
a
a good if you're listening to my
explanation
and it's sparking the right thoughts in
your head
then you know my power is
something that is beneficial to you
right it can also be beneficial to me
because i like
talking about thomas hobbs and unpacking
concepts
and he makes a distinction be between
natural power the eminence of the
faculties of body or mind
right these will come to instrumental
our powers which are acquired by these
and fortune so we'll look at those in
just a moment
then we have value or worth
and this is quite interesting hobbs says
the value or
worth of a person is
the price that somebody would have to
pay
or that would be given for the use of
that person's
power so this is a rather different way
of talking about value right if i say
well you know i value my my wife i value
my friend
i value my children hobbs would you know
come along and say well
that's very nice but i don't mean value
in that same sense
what would you pay what would you give
for the use of their power you know
and in the in the case of children you
say well what am i actually
what do i need from them you know love
and affection i guess
honoring as we're going to talk about in
just a moment uh
carrying on my family name or something
like that they don't actually have that
much to offer from a hobbesian
perspective uh and you can read you know
about that later on in in
one of the later chapters where he talks
about children in the family
this really puts things in a very
different perspective doesn't it
so the value of a person is what they
can give us
what what we're willing to give to them
it could be money it could be time it
could be
honoring it could be pick whatever you
want what are we willing to give to them
so that we can get from them what we
want the good the apparent good or ward
off
some evils so he says that if this is
not absolute
this is the thing dependent upon the
need and judgment of another and we'll
come back to that
in just a moment then we have honor talk
this is a topic that hobbes gives a lot
of examples for
and talks about quite a bit and honor is
tied to this conception
of value or worth he calls it a
manifestation when we honor somebody we
manifest
what we value them as and and you know
this is at a high rate because if he
says to value a person at a high rate is
to honor them
at a low rate is to dishonor them
and high and low is to be understood by
comparison to the rate that each person
sets on themself so
if i think that you know everybody
should get up when i walk into a room
or shut up when i'm talking
or what else we could come up with all
sorts of other
funny examples like that if i do
something good you should send me a
thank you card
right i'm setting that rate on myself
you might not actually
follow that you might be like hey i
already did enough
you know um dignity is related to honor
but dignity comes about not from
individual agents you could say but he
it's what he calls the public worth of a
person
the value set upon them by the
commonwealth
this is what people call dignity and
this value
of this person by the commonwealth is
understood by offices of command
judicature public employment or by names
and titles introduced for distinction
of such value so there's there's a sort
of
you know private although it's not
entirely private it happens
in public and value of honoring right
it's actually very public
and then there's dignity where it's the
community
that is honoring a person or dishonoring
them you could have
you could lack dignity right then we
have at the very end
worthiness so let's look at that he says
worthiness is a thing different from the
worth
or value of a person it's also from
their merit
or dessert what it is that they they
deserve
and consists in a particular power
or ability for that whereof he is said
to be
worthy which particular ability is
usually named
fitness or aptitude and he says for
for the person who's worthyist to be a
commander to be a judge or have any
other
charge is the best fitted with the
qualities required to the best just
discharging of it
and worthiest of riches kind of an
interesting example
is the one who has the qualities most
requisite for the well using
of them so we can be worthy of all
sorts of things and that doesn't tie
in directly to our value this is a very
interesting point
we can deserve
things and that doesn't tie in
necessarily to our worthiness if things
are arranged
you know in the best most rational way
the people who do
in fact have you know the greatest
fitness or aptitude for something
get to do that thing or get tapped to do
that thing they get asked to do that
thing
that's very often not the case right we
live in a society
where things are often much more
arbitrary
and fit in with these other conceptions
which may or may not be on on point
so let's talk about a few other
uh concerns with these let's let's jump
back to
value or worth
from worthiness so right he says it's
the
what would be given for the use of this
person's power it's not absolute
a thing dependent on the need and
judgment of another so it's not
something
that you can say stays the same in all
cases he gives the example
of an able conductor of soldiers is of
great price
great worth in a time of war but in
peace not so
they get dis valued in that case alerted
an uncorrupt judge is worth
much in a time of peace but not in a
time of war and then he says
as in other things so in men not the
seller
but the buyer determines the price for
let a man
as most people do rate themselves at the
highest value they can
their true value is no more
than it is esteemed by others so i can
you know ascen i can think that i'm the
greatest guy
ever but unless you or
somebody else agrees with my assessment
that's not really my value i can be
misled
by myself about what my value actually
is and i probably need to figure out
what it is
by testing out you know what would you
pay for my my services what would you
give
for my goodwill or whatever it's going
to be so
that's kind of interesting let's jump
back to power as well he gives a lot of
examples
of power remember power is the
means to obtain some future apparent
good
so natural power right we come back to
that body and mind
strength form prudence arts eloquence
liberality nobility
instrumental are those powers which
acquired by these or by fortune are
means and instruments to acquire more
what are the examples of these riches
reputation
friends the secret working of god right
which men call
good luck so we have on the one hand
the you know faculties of body and mind
and
on the other hand we have all these
other things that we typically call like
external goods like
you know fortune or
wealth or good friends or things like
that
and then he goes on and he says the
greatest of human powers
is that which is compounded to the
powers of most men
united by consent in one person natural
or civil that has the use of their
powers depending on their will this is
the power of the commonwealth
this is what he's going to call the
power of the sovereign or the
magistrates the stand-ins for the
sovereign
but we could think you know also about
the harnessing of the power
of so many other people by the ceo or
the board of a corporation
right or um you know even with with uh
illegal associations the person who's in
charge is harnessing
the power of others we could think of
this in terms of
social media followings and being able
to get people to do things
you know if you can monetize your
content
be by creating your own website and
having people flock to it because you
have celebrity that's power in hobbesian
terms
and it's coming from what other people
are doing and so he gives a lot of
examples
riches joined deliberately is power why
because
it procures friends and servants
reputation of power
is power because it draws with it the
adherence of those who need protection
take a few other examples whatever
quality maketh
make a person beloved or feared of many
or the reputation of such quality is
power
it's a means to have assistance and
service of many so a lot of times
power isn't something you know real in
and of itself it exists in
our own views on things good
success is power it makes reputation of
wisdom or good fortune
very interesting we often think that
people who are successful are
intelligent
when quite often they were just lucky
right hobbs
observes this in his own time eloquence
is power
nobility is power reputation of prudence
is power
form is power right the sciences he says
are small power because not eminent and
therefore not acknowledged in any
in any person nor uh are at all but in a
few and in
them a few things um arts of public use
however
are very much power like making of
uh engines and other instruments of war
right
and so you know these are all examples
of the ways in which we could
have exercise and be assigned
power what about honor
this hobbs talks about a much greater
length right
manifestation of valuing we don't need
to look at every single example
that he provides because he spends page
after page
discussing it but we can get the general
idea
he says that here we go to obey another
person is to honor
right because nobody obeys them who they
think have no power to help or hurt them
consequently to disobey is to dishonor
and we see these polarities uh these
oppositions back and forth
to give great gifts to a person is to
honor them because it's buying
protection and acknowledging of pleasure
to give little gifts is to dishonor um
to give way to or place to another is to
honor them
to arrogate is to dishonor to show any
sign of love or fear of another
is to honor them for both to love and
fear
is to value to contem right to not care
at all
or less to love or fear than he expects
is to dishonor
why because this is undervaluing a
person
and he goes on with a lot of examples
like that
[Music]
he says to do those things to another
which he takes
for signs of honor or which the law or
custom makes so is to honor so we can
honor a person by doing the
stereotypical actions that are already
acknowledged as
honoring or perhaps idiosyncratically in
the case of that person like
you know if buying a person fountain
pens
they say oh this is to honor me and you
go and you're like hey man here's 10
fountain pens i i really like you you're
you're honoring them
whereas if you went to somebody who
despises fountain pens and did that it
would it would be a dishonoring right
he says to honor those another honors is
to honor them
as a sign of approbation of their
judgment to honor his enemies
on the other hand is to dishonor
that person and so you know we see
example after example
of this and honor can be quite
complex he also talks about what is
considered honorable
in general um but there is one remark
that he comes to
later on he says it doesn't alter the
case of honor
whether an action be it so great and
difficult and consequently a sign of
much power
be just or unjust right or wrong
for honor consistent only in the
reputation of
power it's not about doing the right
thing or doing the wrong thing
this is very different than a lot of
other moral theories
so he said you know for example the
ancient heathen did not think they
dishonored but greatly honored their god
when they introduced
them in their poems committing rapes
thefts and often great but
unclean or unjust acts right
and so you know he's got examples of
this uh
amongst men until they were constituted
great commonwealths it was thought no
dishonor to be a pirate
or highway thief but rather a lawful
trade not only among the greeks but on
among all the other nations so you know
this is this is another
important point and then he goes into a
lot of other discussion about that
but you can you can check that out
yourself these these examples that are
you know fairly minute the general point
is
these are all concepts that we need to
take into account if we want to
understand
how human beings in how they relate to
each other how they
how they understand each other why they
come into conflict or why they might be
inclined to
avoid conflict with each other which is
a really central
feature of this this work leviathan
you